thank you for joining me today my name
is Scott I'm gonna talk about musical
steganography otherwise known as hiding
things in music be a little bit of a
history lesson we're gonna take a look
at some history and then also some demos
which are always fraught with peril
since they're live so this should be
interesting
all right so what is steganography
well we can look that up in the
dictionary and a dictionary definition
would be the art or practice of
concealing a message image or file
within another message image or a file
so essentially hiding something in
something else these days we tend to
think of this in digital terms but
there's a long history of physical
steganography as well this this guy
pictured here his name's Herodotus
around 440 BC he wrote a book called
histories and in it he recounts two
different instances of physical
steganography in the first he talks
about a general who needed to send a
message over to a different city so he
found a soldier shaved his head wrote
the message on his head and apparently
might have been tattooed on his head and
waited for the hair to grow back then he
sent the soldier off and said hey find
this guy tell him to shave your head and
then he'll be able to see the message so
not really the most efficient means of
sending a secret message but you know
it'll work the the second instance the
physical steganography he talks about is
using wax tablets and back in those days
a wax tablet was a thin piece of wood
and then wax spread on top of it and
you'd write on the wax but to hide a
message in that you would simply write
the message on the wood instead put the
wax on top and pretend it's just a
regular writing instrument and whoever
is expecting the message would have to
know to scrape the wax off in order to
read the message
so as you can see the the statue the
statues still look pretty similar but
this guy is johannes try Phineas he was
a German Benedictine abbot he didn't
start out as an abbot though he got
caught in some bad weather
going from his university back to his
hometown and he took shelter at a
monastery and he's like well I think
I'll stay here seemed like a cozy place
he so he ended up being elected Abbot
after after a short time and he
transformed the place into a center of
Education so he's considered a polymath
he's also an occultist and you'll see a
cult is's is an interesting theme here
and he wrote a lot of different books in
1499 he wrote a book called
steganography a-- so you'd wonder what
that was about
well if you read the text it appears to
be about angels and magic but around the
year 1600 somebody published what was
purported to be a key to the
steganography ax and sure enough
it really was a key if you used that
with the text of the book it actually
turns out to be a book about
steganography and cryptography so quite
the unique usage of angels and magic
there twenty years after that he wrote a
book called polygraph eeeh and and
that's pictured on this slide it's it's
pages and pages and pages of over a
thousand different alphabets and tables
with symbols and he wrote this as a way
to give people the ability to create
their own ciphers also in the book he
published his own cipher and it's now
called the tri-c meais Slifer so it's
been around a really really long time we
could we could find other instances to
recount here but we don't really have
the time to do that what we want to do
is talk about musical steganography so
how can we hide messages in music this
is a very non exhaustive list we can use
substitution ciphers backmasking we can
hide images in the audio
we can manipulate frequency and
amplitude we can even do echo
manipulations so manipulation of reverb
some are harder to do than others and we
certainly don't have enough time in this
talk to talk about everything so I'm
going to pick a few to talk about and
demo substitution ciphers this is a huge
huge subject so in the late 1400s there
is a very famous French Renaissance
composer named Justine Despres and he
was very famous for writing masses and
so he wrote a mouse for the Duke of
Ferrara and the really interesting thing
about this was the technique he used to
create the Cantus firmus of the mass
although it's the musical theme he used
a technique called sujeto kobato and
what that means is that he chose some
words split the words up into different
syllables and the words he chose were
air-cool adieu ferrari a and I apologize
I do not speak French so I hope that
sounded ok and he you take the vowel
sounds of each of those syllables and
you match them up with solemnization
syllables
now solemnization syllables we know as
doremi faso Lotito back in those days
they did not use dough they used root so
when you match up the syllables of his
chosen words with the solemnization
syllables you get Rey root or a Loutre
Fahmy Rey which are the notes d c d c b
f e d and it sounds a little bit like
this
[Music]
[Applause]
so no one really knew exactly what what
the songs meant as far as the musical
theme but it actually came out of the
name of the Duke of Ferrara around the
year 1600 we learned two very
interesting things we learn that the
Pope has his own cryptography service
which I had no idea and it's actually
quite neat and that cryptography service
employed standard forms of cryptography
as well as musical cryptography so they
used a cipher that contained nine
different pitches they used eight
different variations for each pitch and
that gave them 72 symbols to cipher
messages and these are actual written
symbols they would they would write
music and made it look like sheet music
transported from place to place and
those would be their secret messages in
the late seventeen hundreds there's a
guy named Philip thickness he was known
as an eccentric he had a really long
military career and he traveled all over
the world as part of the military so he
wrote a bunch of books about his travels
and in 1772 instead of writing a book
about his travels he wrote a book about
cryptography instead and it's called a
treatise on the art of deciphering and
of writing in cipher with an harmonic
alphabet which is a very very long title
but the book is actually pretty neat and
you can find this as scans on Google
books and it talks about a number of
different ways to encipher and decipher
messages but the really cool thing is
this harmonic alphabet that he created
and you can see that it's probably kind
of hard to read on this screen on the
right hand side so he actually shows
different notes on a staff and the
letters that equate to those notes
underneath it and also an example at the
bottom of the page and he thought about
this a bit and he wrote about music
masters and these are these should be
individuals who are well learned in
creating music
they would memorize the harmonic
alphabet and they can talk to each other
in real-time
just by playing music app on another so
that would be fantastic if someone if a
pair of people could really do that that
would be amazing and then he thought a
little bit further and he was and he
tried to come up with a way to kind of
throw people off the scent if you had a
clue that and maybe this is just a
substitution cipher and there's a
message encoded in here he says let's
add some grace notes to the music as
well
and and grace notes are very very short
little notes that are just kind of
tossed in from time to time to make the
music sound interesting but it could
throw somebody off if they're trying to
decode the message in 1808 a biography
about Michael Hayden was published he's
the the slightly less famous brother of
franz joseph haydn
although he was an accomplished composer
in his own right he created his own
musical cypher as well and it's it's
somewhat simplistic it's just an
increasing range of notes starting with
a low G on the bass clef but it points
to the fact that there are a number of
composers right around the same time
that were really really interested in
the in combining music and cryptography
and figuring out how to you know send
secret messages through their
compositions but a lot of it was was
about the composer's having fun it was
common for composers to use their own
names as motifs and the music they
created they'd use names of loved ones
they'd even take names of cities that
were important to them and put those in
their music as well so at this point in
time there were really two main methods
that they would use to do this and the
first method is the German method and
it's pretty simple you take the notes a
through G and those would be the letters
A through G the only exception to that
is B natural was used for H and B flat
was used for B a flat was asked and a
flat was the combination of a
and s so that gave them about ten
letters to work with which isn't a whole
lot but you can still have some fun with
it so so Bach used his name all over the
place in in his compositions and using
the German method of encoding that would
be a b-flat and a a C and a B natural so
here's an example from the art of fugue
in which he incorporated his name into
the music
oh well try that again huh come on you
can do
[Music]
all right Shuman also used his name a
lot
he abbreviated his name s CH a because
there was no other possible way there
was no you or M or n that he could
actually use with the German method of
encoding so he created a piece called
carnival and the interesting thing about
that was that piece was split into 22
different sections and in each section
he would either use his name or the word
ash for Ash Wednesday ash also stood for
the city that his then fiancee was born
in and he would kind of mix them up and
and tweak the notes a bit and two
different octaves and he used those
across all 22 sections of the music in
right in the middle he he actually wrote
out and published as part of the piece a
kind of a key to the cryptograms that he
put into the music it wasn't meant to be
played as part of the entire composition
but some players actually did record it
and this is what that middle section
sounds like
[Music]
so the interesting thing is is if you
had no idea you wouldn't even be able to
tell necessarily that they were trying
to communicate any kind of message and
and that was the kind of kind of the
point in doing this is they're having
fun
putting little messages in the music
that 99% of the people listening would
never get so even with limited letters
we can still have a little bit of fun
with this we can encode words like beef
or cabbage or cash or cage so we can
express our interest in buying a lot of
beef and cabbage I guess in in a
composition of our own choosing so
here's where I'll here's where I'll show
you a little demo so this portion will
be in Haskell it's a language called
tidal cycles which is built in Haskell
and tidal cycles is about creating
patterns and patterns are really magical
they look like strings they're really
pattern objects and funk doors in the
house cool language so we can apply
functions to a pattern and have some fun
with it and making a substitution cipher
actually turns out to be fairly easy we
need to create a function that will
return the the substitutions between
letter and note and then we need to map
that substitution function over some
plain text that we wish to encode all
right so here we go so you'll see a lot
of a lot of the lines look sort of like
this d1 simply specifies an output so we
don't have to worry about that so much
but the the interesting parts here is
that we always have to specify an N this
tells title cycles what notes to play
and it just looks like a string we give
it a note letter and an octave separate
everything by spaces we also always have
to have an S and the string after an S
is the name of a synth to use in the
underlying synth software
so this should just give us four notes
[Music]
and it's name is tidal cycles it loose
so it doesn't just stop playing for you
so we need some utility functions to
make this work we have a function called
insert space when we actually convert
plain text to encoded text it it comes
back in an array so as you saw above
here every note has to have a space in
between so we have a function to put
those spaces in between and then we also
need a function that will take that
array turn it back to a string and then
convert it back into a tidal cycles
pattern so that it can play it so with
those we define some very simple
substitution functions so this one here
is called G conf and you can see that
I'm mapping ABC and so on to the correct
notes that we want to play so
a3 bf3 and so on and so forth all right
and so when we want to actually convert
some text we simply say map use the
mapping function G conf and then the
string of text that we're converting and
use the arrayed a pattern function to
turn it back into a pattern and give
that all to N and now we get
[Music]
Anshuman
and everyone's here favorite 'if
and of course cash gotta pay for the be
[Music]
alright so looking at the second method
here it's called the French method and
using this method we can actually encode
all the letters of the alphabet so at
the very top of this table here the
letters A through G are correspond to
the notes a through G again and then all
the other letters are placed into the
grid alphabetically and so in order to
figure out what note to use for a
specific letter we just look vertically
and so we find out that that the note C
is the encoding for the letters cjq and
X now on one hand this is really awesome
because now we can we can encode any
English letter on the downside though
this makes it really really hard for
somebody to make sense of the message
you're sending them because they'll see
a string of notes and they'll see a C
and they'll have absolutely no idea if
that's supposed to be a see a jaq or an
x so you'd have to apply a second level
of crypt analysis to the whole thing to
work out letter frequency and see if you
can make that work and that that's just
extra work that cohen wants to do but
i'm happy because now i can encode my
whole name and it's this whole string
below and I can play that for you so
here again I just created a French
method substitution function that goes
through all the layers of the alphabet
and it lets me do this
[Music]
it's a catchy tune I kind of like my
name yeah I think I'll keep it so moving
a little bit further in time getting to
more modern days there there were other
composers who really liked to play with
ciphers and music and and how they can
mix the two together Ravel Debussy and
messy on also played around with this
and instead of doing like one-to-one
substitutions they they wanted to get a
little more complex with it mostly to
make it sound better because the German
method and the French method while it
worked it didn't necessarily create full
compositions that that sound like really
you know how they wanted to wanted it to
sound like so messy on in particular did
some cool stuff and this really really
blurry set of notes that you see on the
slide and unfortunately that's that's
the best I could find this is the
substitution cipher that he used when
creating his that composition
meditations and he actually used this to
encode quotations from Thomas Aquinas
and the cool thing is is that the cipher
that he uses actually fits his musical
style pretty well and here's a little
snippet
[Music]
[Applause]
so that's actually been analyzed many
times and it really does include
quotations and you can find those out on
the Internet so we can pretty easily
create our own cipher using these same
methods it's it's really a matter of
just creating that that substitution
function so I'll play some music using
our own substitution cipher and I'm
going to use a program called score
cloud to attempt to generate a score
from the music because it's one thing to
play in coded music it's another thing
to actually try to decode it so let's
let's see how that goes I'm going to
start the music let's get to the right
place this is a very simple substitution
function it's just increasing notes so
it'll be hello strange loop 2018
[Music]
and we'll let this report
[Music]
okay so we recorded some audio will hit
analyze and came up with far fewer notes
than I thought it would but that's okay
so this is kind of what it does and and
that's probably let's see if I can get
that a little bit bigger there we go so
score cloud actually does a pretty
decent job of taking audio and
converting it into the correct pitches
where where it seems to fail is being
really consistent on getting the timing
right and the duration of the notes
right but but for the purposes of
decoding the music we're we're we're
we're doing a strict note two letter
substitution that's probably an okay
thing I will show this one though so
this this is from a recording of the
Bach in the German method that I played
earlier and it actually does a pretty
good job and so this is actually a
b-flat that is an a that's a C and that
is a D natural which is which are the
notes that it should translate into so
so software such as this can be used you
know in limited ways to decode music for
us so we can think about making this
even more complex
so creating ciphers that encode multiple
notes per letter maybe something that
only encodes every nth note for a letter
instead of every single note we can also
manipulate pitches and detune pitches
and change note lengths to encode
letters as well so that's enough about
substitution ciphers it's a really huge
subject and brings in all kinds of stuff
about cryptography but let's let's look
into backmasking a bit so we'll
transport ourselves to the to the the
near past so this would be the 50s and
60s a fun and exciting time for rock
music but actually we really want to go
back to the year 1877 because that's
kinda
where it all started the staff are
looking gentleman sitting by that weird
piece of equipment is Thomas Edison he
invented the phonograph doesn't look
quite like our record players of today
but it works very similarly and to the
surprise of no one he and others working
on the phonograph immediately tried to
figure out what happens if we try to
play things in Reverse so they have
started a trend a trend continued by
this interesting looking guy his name's
Aleister Crowley
he was a well-known occultist here we
have the occults coming up again and he
was an odd duck he was possibly also a
British spy which was interesting but
his claim to fame is that he claims that
he was on his honeymoon and was visited
by a disembodied voice and this voice
dictated to him the book of law which he
used as the basis for a religion that he
founded called ulema
and it's all about practicing magic so
he wrote a slew of books for his
religion one of which was called magic
book for in the early 1900's and it was
a long treatise on magic and what he
wanted his practitioners to do was to
think backwards by external means in
order to train themselves and he
specifically said that that you should
listen to records backwards in order to
do this so it's kind of a weird and
interesting link there the musique
concrète mute movement would use small
bits of audio and kind of sprinkled them
around and rearrange them to create
interesting sound collage most of that
work was done on on record players but
in the 50s the 1950s this time tape
recorders became widely available so
this allowed this allowed people to to
get even tinier and tinier bits of music
to to make collages with but the most
important things are is that it allowed
ease allowed
people easily manipulate speed of audio
playback and easily reverse the audio as
well so coming out of that a
little-known band called The Beatles in
1966 they were recording their album
revolver and John Lennon recollected
that he was under the influence of
marijuana and decided to play some of
the tapes backwards he thought it was
pretty cool brought it to the rest of
the band and they liked it as well their
producer had a completely different
story and said the whole band was it was
doing that the whole time they all
thought it was great I don't know which
is the correct recollection but their
song rain was the first recorded song
with with backwards audio built into the
song and that
all right so so you kind of hear the the
backwards music in there it has a really
distinct sound when you hear something
backwards so that kind of kicked off
this this big thing where people would
look for audio that was backwards in
every song and so things happen like
this
here's another Beatles song I'm so tired
it's really hard to hear so that was
reversing that audio purportedly it says
Paul is a Ted man Miss and Miss and Miss
M but that's completely unintentional
it's just the recording artifact it it
never happened but people found things
like this all over the place
and this caused some problems big
controversy there are so many false
positives that there were congressional
hearings about this the PMRC got
involved many people are saying rock
bands are in league with Satan people
kept hearing Satan all over the place so
there's here's a cup there's a couple of
Clips here that they have unintentional
backmasking stairway to heaven Queens
and other one bites the dust and and
then because of all the controversy some
bands decided to deliberately put things
into their music like Pink Floyd Slayer
and even though The Electric Light
Orchestra so in a stairway to heaven is
kind of injury
alright that's forwards and here's what
it here's what it is in Reverse
[Music]
so so human brains have this amazing
ability to find pattern where there
might not really be any pattern and this
is one of those cases it does not really
say oh here's to my sweet Satan
it really doesn't Pink Floyd however did
this on purpose
[Music]
and then in Reverse
[Applause]
[Music]
so we have discovered the secret message
which is good because I was we like
secret messages in our songs all right
but so this is actually really really
really easy to do in tidal cycles
there's a speed parameter and if you set
it to negative one it will play the
sample in Reverse so somewhere here yeah
here it is I recorded the sample for you
so path Scott created dance and I
haven't loaded into audacity I put some
background music in there I heard will
help and if I reverse that and play it I
hope you're having a good time I hope
you're having a good time yeah yeah all
right I hope you're having a good time
too path Scott was so prophetic so
backmasking is is fun and fun and pretty
easy to do in the title cycle software
all right so pictures we can hide
pictures in music - alright so in 1999
of a little-known techno artist named FX
twin released an EP called window liquor
yeah it was pretty catchy tune had a had
a memorable video for those who have
seen it but a couple years later some
people out in internet land decided to
extract all the audio off the EP and run
it through a spectrum analyzer and
specifically somebody pointed to track 2
of the EP it it didn't have a
traditional name its name was this giant
equation so near the end of the track if
you look at the spectrum analysis it
looks like this or it goes forward
[Music]
yeah so if you've just been scanning and
watching this go across your screen and
then you see that you'd be like what in
the world so so yeah so FX twins has a
certain sense of humor he deliberately
put that in a song he actually put all
their designs and some of those some of
his other songs as well but this is
really the most memorable one so that's
pretty cool other other groups did that
as well Venetian Snares put some nice
pictures of cats in their songs and even
Nine Inch Nails and I have absolutely no
idea what that is but it looks kind of
cool alright so how do you do that so on
the Mac there is this really neat bit of
software called medicine that can be
used to do this on Windows there is a
less neat piece of software called
coagula you'll need some sort of audio
editor to merge things together and a
bit of software called sonic visualizer
can be used to do the spectrum analysis
so I'll just say about medicine it's
really really cool but it's not free
unfortunately and it's quite expensive
or at least I thought it was expensive
and unfortunately the demo can't export
audio so my demo does not show medicine
it does show coagula so hopefully we
have no it's Howard off this doesn't
take too long so I'll get this going and
you know this is the fun of the live
demo here mm-hmm
we'll go back to the slides so basically
we you can import an image into coagula
as a bitmap coagula can export WAV files
for your image and we'll merge that
together with whatever song we want
using audacity into a single audio file
and then we'll import the result into
sonic visualizer and we'll see the
results
let's see how we're doing here oh there
we go all right get this going here no
that's not what I wanted to do come on
all right here we go all right all in a
day's work
all right we'll open an image and I did
try this two ways with my face and also
with hi strange loop this is actually
easier to see you so I'll use this so
it's pretty easy you open the image you
have to surrender it sounds horrible
right so it's actually taking the the
the colors and the in the location of of
the different colors in the image and
converting that to audio and it sounds
bad so just like effects effects twins
face sounded horrible hi strange loop
I'm sorry sounds horrible so we'll go
ahead and we'll see no I don't need to
say that
so I pre imported all this into audacity
and so the top one here is the strange
loop image and the bottom part is some
actual music
and then we get real music
so this has already been exported into a
file for us and we'll go ahead and open
that up all right so there's our file
and Sonic visualizer is pretty cool we
can add a spectrogram and we'll change
that to make it a little easier to see
and we can zoom in a bit and there is
our image and our music so it's really
it's really actually not too hard to go
ahead and hide whatever cool stuff you
want your music the only hard part is
putting it in a place where no one will
notice that it sounds horrible because
because it does
alright so music and steganography are a
lot of fun what I've shown today is
really only the tip of the iceberg
there's a lot of different techniques
that you can use to hide your own
messages in audio files so really the
sky's the limit here you can get really
really creative with this special thanks
to Alex McLean who who created tidal
cycles both him and and an acquaintance
been gold helped me out with some of the
initial sample code to make this all
work and that's all I got thank you very
much for listening
[Applause]